you know you'd said earlier that you'd
like to go into a film's idea and
subject without a real biased to it hmm
how do you feel about filmmaking as a
form of activism I think it's great I
mean I I think that i think that i think
that people make documentary films for
different reasons and some people make
them because they see a real problem in
the world are real injustice in the
world and they go out and they try to
advocate against it and they try to
change the way things the way things are
i mean that's that's very very common it
within the documentary filmmaking ranks
and i feel that that's I feel it's great
if that's what people want to do that's
what they should do for me and I think I
think documentary film advocacy
certainly is important I think where
some of these films sometimes lose their
way is that people are either only
preaching to the choir which I which I
think has limited sort of effect it sort
of doesn't really change anything and i
also would really draw the line on you
know on on people who are sort of fast
and loose with the truths with the truth
or the truths of the story i think that
i think it's really important if you're
trying to make a case to be as
transparent and as honest as you can be
if in telling your story you become
dishonest or are telling half-truths
then maybe your argument is not as
strong as you think it is you know you
should be able to lay out the facts and
and present your argument in a very
honest and and compelling way and i
think that's how you make an effective
impactful documentary film some people
don't always do that and I and I have
really strong feelings against that
approach because
you know that's just more misinformation
more sort of shading of the truths or
more deceitfulness which which I know I
which I don't think is the way to go one
of the things I love about Jon Stewart's
show The Daily Show is they just they
just hammer you with the truth they just
they just win their arguments based on
truth in fact and good humor you know
Mark Twain was the same way if you're
winning all your arguments by lying to
people or by not presenting the whole
story that's I think audiences are
really getting smarter than ever and
they catch on to that quickly and your
film ends up losing a lot of integrity
you